all right going to the phones is Brianna
from Washington hey Brianna welcome to
the show hi thank you for taking my call
absolutely it's a Brianna or Brianna so
make sure you get it it's Brianna
Brianna good okay perfect
all right how can I help hi we have a
single income family and we have a truck
payment that is actually more than our
annual take-home pay and we're looking
into selling it we've been talking to
our parents for some advice they think
it's a terrible idea of a seller trust
because it is a newer truck it's very
reliable we have a five month old
daughter and we actually just moved to
Washington in the past two months
because of the military so we are
families in Florida so we're across the
country from anyone tell anyone that we
know
so we're not quite sure what to do
because we do have some negative equity
in this truck all right and how much you
guys make a year twenty one twenty one
thousand six hundred and how much is the
truck it we owe to twenty eight thousand
and two hundred dollars okay well number
one thank you guys for your service and
the sacrifice that you guys are making
so just I appreciate that very much
yeah I would sell the car like get a
heartbeat 100% I mean your car even
would be negative equity yes absolutely
get it out of here because okay you're
underwater so you may take out a small
loan for the difference but when you're
looking at your annual income I mean
yeah just the math of it I don't I don't
care if the family situation I don't
care where your family is across the
country I mean none of that matters at
this point the math is like blaring and
yeah 100% sell the car but it's
something that a lot of people and I get
this as a mom cuz you said we have a
five month old so yes there is something
to wanting to protect your children and
all of that but I can tell you a used
truck will do the exact same thing and
so you can go show me it's a it's
amazing that what we put in our vehicles
it's like we've bought in to a little
bit of this like fear tactic I feel like
as a parent cuz I hear this all the time
for people oh we got to get a new car
because we're having a family you know
we want keep them safe and reliable I'm
like yeah yeah absolutely but there are
definitely safe and reliable you
used cars that you guys can do do you
guys have any other debt besides the
truck nope that's it the only one we
paid off everything else
awesome well congrats on that yeah well
it's a kind of a short answer for you
Briana but yep definitely go and sell
that truck man our cars it's amazing I
mean Dave's line at the beginning of the
show is the BMWs just the status symbol
of choice you know versus the paid off
mortgage today and I'm like Ana de is
there something about our cars that we
just get attached to that we again buy
into this lie that okay well we have to
have a great nice car it has to feel
good I have to feel safe in it and a
used car does the exact same thing you
guys until you have a million dollar net
worth I want you to buy used all the
time I just sold my car it was ten years
old and we didn't want to we had to get
a bigger car because now we're family
three and all the kiddos would not just
would not fit in our other car so we did
have to sell it but it was ten years old
and I'm not gonna lie I like just died a
little inside because we sold it number
one because I loved that car and the
number two we sold it for a minivan yes
we have a minivan now I can't believe it
but it's true we do and I love my
minivan but man that 10 year old car was
like it ran and ran and ran and ran I
was like I hate having to buy another
car when this one is just fine but we
couldn't fit into it so logistical with
car seats we had to get a different car
but yeah it's something with our cars in
our attachment but yeah Briana I would
definitely definitely get it out of
there